we're in Washington right now I've been
here on my life and I can say I've never
seen this city crazier or more paranoid
or more tense or more dumb here's an
example three years ago Brett Kavanaugh
I made what was obviously a joke about
his time in high school here it is
fortunately we had it we had a good
saying that we've held firm to the to
this day as the Dean was reminding me
before before the talk which is what
happens at Georgetown Prep stays at
Georgetown Prep that's been a good thing
for all of us yeah so he's obviously
admitting a felony sex crime there no it
was a joke and it's clearly irrelevant
what we're talking about today but don't
tell the more literal-minded humorless
members of the Senate how about
Elizabeth Warren she tweeted this I
can't imagine any parent accepting this
view is this really what America wants
this next Supreme Court justice if you
can even imagine texting something like
that or putting it on Twitter mindless
Ann Coulter's writer author of
resistance is futile how the Trump
hating left has lost his collective mind
as if she needed another example of it
she joins us tonight so what do you make
of the fact I was trying get a straight
answer for my last guest and I'm not
sure I even think of him what do you
make of the fact that Diane Feinstein is
saying I'm not sure I believe Christine
Ford now well Diane Feinstein has always
been one of my favorite senators a
Republican or a Democrat I was sort of
surprised she was the one who held on to
this letter I don't I don't think the
big issue is but it's the 11th hour I
think the big issue is last week we
start started getting polls showing the
Democrats have a shot at taking the
Senate they really want to stop this
nomination it's been kind of hilarious
listening to the Democrats Oh on the New
York Times editorial page and Schumer
and Blumenthal we need a major FBI
investigation as you point out there's
nothing to investigate they want to
appoint a blue-ribbon Commission and
maybe you know they'll wrap up their
work sometime next February it really is
just purely for sure so can I ask them
so I mean why not an independent counsel
and he can take me before or five years
to get to the bottom of it why would the
Republican look this I am giving
everybody every benefit of every doubt
I'm not attacking Ford who again as I
said last night I've heard is a nice
person but this is a political tactic
designed
prevent the president from putting his
nominee on the court why Republicans in
the Congress playing along with this I
think some of them and this is this is
the only thing that I think makes it
dangerous for Republicans for Kavanagh
and for the Republic because there are
certain Republicans in the Senate who so
hate Trump they would put their egos
above the good of the country and and
what so many Republicans said about
voting and every four years say about
voting for any Republican we have to do
it for the Supreme Court nominees no
maybe not for Ben Sasse maybe not for
for senator bob Corker they just so hate
Trump that could end up hurting hurting
Cavanaugh but I I think your points that
if they get away with this there's then
you have CNN running the country it's
not even just the Democrats running the
country it's the media running the
country because this allegation could be
made against anyone at any time
absolutely unnhhh on disprovable the the
New York Times I wanted to mention your
since you cited Teddy Kennedy one of the
great things in the New York Times
editorial on this case was to say that
things were totally different in the
1980s that's why this woman dr. Ford
didn't report it at the time because you
remember the 1980s talk are you used to
be able to there were sexual assault
like mad every place there proof of this
that women weren't taken seriously in
the 1980s was to link to an article in
The Washington Post citing the New York
Times treatment of the accuser of
William Kennedy Smith so yes the
Kennedys they've always had free rein to
rape murder and the New York Times would
go after the accusers but that's really
what the division is here this isn't a
new thing as long as you are a presumes
white male Republican whether it's the
Duke Lacrosse case or oh that dastardly
Haven Monahan
in the Rolling Stone story about the
frat boys gang raping the gal the whole
thing turned out to be fake there is no
Haven Monahan or now a lot of this this
statements about Brett Kavanaugh like
from Krugman oh he's smirking and a lot
on Twitter and elsewhere oh he's a white
male is white privilege if you fit the
narrative you are guilty and there is no
coming back from that and it's not just
Democrats and the media running the
country it's any white male can be
accused with an evidence free Act well
you should want to judge people on the
basis of their immutable characteristics
period so I don't know why the leftist
I'll say that Ann Coulter thank you it's
great to see you tonight thank you